At the end of the 19th century, David Hilbert,
who was a famous mathematician at the time,
Listed 20 problems that he thought were going to
direct the future of 20th Century  mathematics.
But one of them, Hilbert's 3rd
problem, was so easy that
Hilbert's student solved it
2 years after he posed it.
So that's the one I
want to explain today.
Yeah, I would call it
Hilbert's 3rd problem,
but it's maybe, maybe let's call it the equidecomposability problem.
If you have two
polygons 𝑃₁ and 𝑃₂--
Brady Haran: So no rules about convex or concave?
Daniel Litt: No rules about convex or concave.
All you need is a finite number of straight
lines which meet and form a closed figure.
So here are 2 polygons, 𝑃₁ and 𝑃₂,
and they have the same area,
then you can cut off 𝑃₁ with finitely many
straight lines and rearrange the pieces to get 𝑃₂.
So here's an example of a
polygon which I've already pre-cut.
It's a parallelogram and here's how we can
rearrange it into a rectangle with the same area.
Just move this triangle over here.
So that was pretty easy.
So the proof actually gives you an
algorithm for cutting up a polygon
and decomposing
it into another one.
So Hilbert's
3rd question,
which was in 1898, I think, was, "Is the same thing true in three dimensions?"
So what do I
mean by that?
I mean if you have two polyhedra,
so three-dimensional figures
which are made out of, you know,
flat faces edges, and vertices,
and if they have the same volume,
can you cut one up into pieces with finitely many
cuts and rearrange the pieces to make the other?
Brady Haran: Well, in my
intuition, would be yes.
It's because if you put two polyhedra
with the same volume into, like, a bath,
they'll displace the
same amount of water.
Daniel Litt: So, yeah, so if you were allowed to
melt the polyhedra, you could definitely do it.
but if you're only allowed to use
straight cuts, it turns out you can't,
and this is what
Dehn proved,
and I think Hilbert
probably expected this,
so I think he probably tried with the
cube, tried to cut it up into pieces,
and rearrange it
into a tetrahedron,
so that's a figure with 4 faces all a bunch of triangles,
which are the same, and he couldn't do it.
and so the actual
question was:
can you cut up a cube with finitely many knife cuts
and rearrange the pieces to get a tetrahedron?
And Dehn ended up proving that you can't do that.
Brady Haran: You can't do it?
Daniel Litt: You can't do it.
Brady Haran: What changes between 2 and 3
dimensions that suddenly makes it impossible?
Daniel Litt: Yeah, so I can explain
at least the idea behind Dehn's proof.
Dehn was the student of Hilbert, and it was his
thesis problem to solve Hilbert's third question,
it's one of the greatest theses of all time,
and so what was his idea?
Well, his idea was that, well, let's say you have
2 polygons, which have a different area.
Why can't you cut one up
and rearrange it to the other?
Well, the area is invariant under this action
of cutting it and then moving the pieces around;
the area
doesn't change.
So Dehn's idea was that you should
find some invariant of a polyhedron
that doesn't change when you cut
it up and move the pieces around,
and then he wanted to compute that invariant for the
cube and for the tetrahedron and see if they're different.
So what that means
is that, you know,
no matter how you take the cube,
cut it up, and move the pieces around,
if these invariants are different,
you can't get a tetrahedron.
Brady Haran: The deal breaker,
the thing that can't change--
Daniel Litt: The obstruction, yeah, to move, changing one piece
and one polyhedron into another polyhedron.
Brady Haran: What was it? Are you going to tell me?
Daniel Litt: I'll tell you,
it's kind of complicated.
So we should maybe we
should build up to it.
Let's prove this
1833 theorem.
So this is equidecomposability for polygons.
All right, so there are several
steps. So what's the goal?
Let me first make the
problem a little bit easier.
Let's try to cut up
a polygon of area 𝐴,
so 𝐴 could be 5,
and rearrange the pieces
into a 1 by 𝐴 rectangle.
And I claim
that's enough.
Why is that? It's because cutting something up and
rearranging the pieces is a reversible operation,
so if you have a
polygon of area 𝐴,
you can make it into
1 by 𝐴 rectangle
and another polygon with area 𝐴; you can
make it into the same 1 by 𝐴 rectangle,
and then, well, how do you get from your
first polygon to your second one?
you just pass through the 1 by 𝐴 rectangle
that you are able to make both of them into,
so it's enough to do this.
so we can assume one of 𝑃₁
and 𝑃₂ is just a rectangle.
What's the first step?
It's easy.
You just cut it
into triangles.
Step 2 is a
little trickier.
We're going to turn triangles into parallelograms
All right, so we have our triangle. What do we do?
We take the midpoints
of these two sides,
we draw the line through them so that
this has the same length as this,
and then, well, we just move
this triangle over here.
So, here's a triangle,
And now you can cut it up
and turn it into a parallelogram.
Brady Haran: So any triangle can be
parallel, er, parallelogram-ized.
Daniel Litt: Yeah,
that's exactly right.
All right, now we're gonna turn
parallelograms into rectangles.
So here what
do you do?
You just drop a perpendicular like this
and then move this triangle over here.
Here's my parallelogram and I'm
going to turn it into a rectangle.
That was easy.
All right, so now, we have some rectangle,
which has the same area as our original polygon.
Well, we do this for every triangle we got.
And we get a bunch of rectangles,
and now, we're gonna make
it into a 1 by 𝐴 rectangle.
So here's
some rectangle,
and what we do is we
measure out a distance 1,
let's say, 1 inch or so on the bottom,
and draw a rectangle
with the same area.
Now we connect
these two vertices,
and it turns out that the
triangle 𝐴𝐵𝐶 is the same--
it's congruent to
the triangle 𝐷𝐸𝐹,
So we can start by moving this triangle and just sliding it down here.
Now, there's a
little bit left over,
it's these two triangles, and it
turns out they're also the same;
it turns out the triangle 𝐴𝐷𝐺 is
the same as the triangle 𝐶𝐹𝐻.
How do we cut this rectangle up into this
one which has the desired property
to 1 by Area rectangle? Just move this
triangle over here and this triangle over here.
Okay, and that
finishes the proof.
We first cut into triangles,
then we cut into parallelograms,
then we cut into rectangles, then
we cut it special rectangles.
And then we undo all of that to get into the other
polygon that we wanted to aim at at the beginning.
Brady Haran: Cool.
Daniel Litt: Okay.
So, why did
this work?
It worked because we had this one invariant
that we knew to search for the area,
where we were gonna search for a 1 by 𝐴 rectangle,
and it turns out that there's a secret
hidden invariant in three dimensions
that will stop us from
running this algorithm.
All right, so let's see
what Dehn did.
So what he wanted to do is he wanted
to take a cube and a tetrahedron,
which have the
same volume,
and he wanted to show you
couldn't cut this up in any way
with a finite number of slices and
rearrange the pieces to get this one,
so he had to come up with some
way of distinguishing the two,
something that is different
about these guys,
and it doesn't change when you cut
them up and rearrange the pieces.
Brady Haran: Daniel, you're saying he
wanted to show you couldn't do it
That's right.
Brady Haran: Wouldn't he rather have shown
you could do it? Did he already know--
Brady Haran: He probably tried, I mean,
yeah, so why do you conjecture
something's impossible?
you, like, to try really hard and
try really hard and you just fail,
and you get really frustrated and you're
like, "I'm gonna prove this can't be done."
and in Dehn's case he
was able to do it, right?
So here's the
basic observation.
so let's zoom in on some
edge of a polyhedron
and there's two
invariants of this edge.
You can look at--
you can look at the length,
So 𝓁 is the
length of an edge,
and there's another invariant which
I'll call 𝜃. That's the dihedral angles.
It's the angle it takes to get
from this face to this one,
so it's the angle swept out by my hands;
I moved from one face to the other
It's the angle it takes to get
from this face to this one,
so that's an angle
between 0 and 2𝜋
So what's the observation?
The observation is there's two ways to cut,
so one is you
can cut like this.
so you can cut with a plane that kind of passes through the edge.
It cuts this edge in half, right?
Brady Haran: It changes the length.
But it leaves the dihedral
angle the same, right?
And the lengths of the two edges you get
are the-- they sum to the original length.
So if you cut, let's say,
vertically, you get (𝓁₁, 𝜃)
and (𝓁₂, 𝜃), so the two lengths of
these two pieces, 𝓁₁ and that's 𝓁₂,
the 𝜃's are the same and
𝓁₁+𝓁₂ is the original length.
Right, so the other thing you
can do is cut along the edge
so the other thing you
can do is cut like this,
and then you get, well, two
edges there, on these two pieces.
They have the same length
and angles, summed together,
so you get
(𝓁, 𝜃₁) and (𝓁, 𝜃₂),
and here, 𝜃₁+𝜃₂ is the original 𝜃.
so the two dihedral angles add together
to give you what you started with.
And, so, Dehn's idea
was to stare at this
and just make it into an invariant
in the most brutal way possible.
So how did he do it?
So here's the invariant: so you take the
sum of the following symbols 𝓁ᵢ⊗𝜃ᵢ
We're here-- this runs over
the edges of the polyhedron.
so what you do is you take the length of
each edge and the angle at each edge
and write down just this sum, which
is right now just a sum of symbols.
It doesn't
mean anything.
So, let's figure out what it means.
Brady Haran: How you add an angle to a length?
That's right, it doesn't. Well, so we're sort of we're formally multiplying them
and then we're adding
these symbols together,
so let me let me
say where this lives.
So this lives in something, which is
called the Real numbers, tensored with Real numbers mod 2π
so let me explain
what this set is.
Brady Haran: You're cracking
out the new symbols on me now?
Daniel Litt: That's right, yeah.
So, let's say what this is:
it's an element of this thing.
This weird object is just
a sum 𝑎₁⊗𝑏₁+𝑎₂⊗𝑏₂.
these are just symbols so far,
all the way up to 𝑎_𝑛⊗𝑏_𝑛 for some 𝑛,
where these 𝑎ᵢ and 𝑏ᵢ
are just real numbers,
but we say two symbols like this are
the same if certain rules are satisfied.
So what rules?
Well, first of all, 𝑎⊗𝑏 is the same as 𝑎⊗(𝑏+2𝜋).
What is this expressing?
It's just expressing that if you take an angle
and you add 2𝜋 to it, you get the same angle.
All right, now we have
some other rules.
We say that 𝑎₁⊗𝑏+𝑎₂⊗𝑏=(𝑎₁+𝑎₂)⊗𝑏
So you're allowed to add on the left
if the 𝑏's on the right are the same.
So what does
this express?
It expresses that if you've 2𝜃's which are the same,
if you cut, you can add two lengths.
That's just
expressing this.
All right,
there's one more rule:
It's just the same thing on the other side.
So it says that if
you have 𝑎⊗𝑏₁+𝑎⊗𝑏₂,
that's the same
as 𝑎⊗(𝑏₁+𝑏₂).
And that's just
expressing this rule.
So this is just a set of symbols which
are allowed to add and subtract,
but they follow some funny
rules when you do that,
and Dehn's Invariant is
this object inside this set,
And he's saying, "Well,
no matter how you
cut off your shape,
When you compute this invariant,
you get the same thing in this set."
That's called
the Dehn Invariant.
Brady Haran: I'm not gonna pretend
to totally understand it,
but I believe you. What's wrong
with having an invariant though?
What does that mean?
I can't just, you know,
be strategic and make millions of cuts and
still be able to build these things--
Yes, and the point
of this invariant is that
it doesn't change when
you make a cut, right?
You get more edges
and you get more angles,
but because of these rules over here
and equivalently these rules over here,
the invariant in the
set just doesn't change
So now what you have to do
is give into a polyhedron.
You have to compute this invariant and
sometimes, they're different, right?
So Dehn's observation
Showed that the invariant of the cube is
not the same as the invariant of the tetrahedron.
Brady Haran: So this invariant is
almost like a fingerprint or DNA.
Daniel Litt: That's exactly right.
Brady Haran: It's unique to the polyhedron.
Yeah, so it turns out and
Dehn didn't know this,
but it was proven
about 30 years later
that if you know the volume of a polyhedron
and you know the Dehn invariant,
then that determines the polyhedron up to this
operation of cutting and moving the pieces around.
So in fact,
it's true that
if you have two polyhedra with the same
volume and the same Dehn invariant,
then you can cut one up and get the
other one by rearranging the pieces.
But here, Dehn, what Dehn did is just showed that if
you have two polyhedra with different invariants,
You just can't do that.
You're stuck.
There's no way you
can change the Dehn there.
Brady Haran: Because once you've
got that Dehn invariant,
you're stuck with it for life.
Daniel Litt: That's right. Yeah.
There's nothing you can do, at least with
this operation of cutting with a knife
and moving the pieces around that changes
that invariant. That's why it's called an invariant.
Brady Haran: What's the Dehn invariant of a cube? Is it like--
Daniel Litt: Yes, we can do the Dehn Invariant
of a cube. That's a good example.
So let's do the cube.
So luckily, all the edges are the same.
So we only have to
compute with one edge.
So let's say we have a
cube of side length 1,
and then what do
we have to do?
We have to compute the angle.
Well, that's just 90°, or 𝜋/2.
So for each edge contributes 1⊗(𝜋/2),
and then how many edges are there?
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6,
7, 8, 9, 10, 11, 12.
Well because of this rule that if
the second guys are the same,
we can add
the first guys.
This is just the same
as 12⊗(𝜋/2), if you'd like.
That's the Dehn Invariant
of the cube.
Now, the tetrahedron is a little harder while you compute this angle
which I'll just call 𝜃, a little bit of a pain
to compute it, so I won't do it here.
You have to compute what side length gives you a volume of 1,
so let's call it 𝓁.
And how many
edges are there?
There's 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6,
so you get 6𝓁⊗𝜃.
and once you compute what these actually
are, you'll see that it isn't the same as this.
Brady Haran: So if I gave you a cube and
said, "Turn this into a tetrahedra,"
Daniel Litt: Yeah.
Brady Haran: You're gonna say, "Yeah, I can do that,"
but unfortunately, I'm gonna
have to change it's volume.
No, unfortunately you have to do both
with the volume and the Dehn invariant.
Oh you have to change both
Because, of course, the volume doesn't change
when you cut and move things around either,
So those are exactly the
two invariants of a polyhedron--
the volume and
the Dehn Invariant.
Dehn's big contribution was to discover that this is
there is the second one. Nobody knew that before.
Brady Haran: How come
I can do it when I melt them?
Daniel Litt: Yeah,
that's a good question.
That's because melting them doesn't
change the volume, right?
but it does change this invariant;
you've destroyed all the edges,
so how would you even
compute the Dehn invariant?
In fact, it turns out in higher dimensions, there are also even more invariants.
We don't know what
they are in general,
So that's an
open problem.
If you want to think about, I don't
know, 12 dimensional polyhedra,
and one you can cut one
up and get the other one.
It's actually a really beautiful
and exciting part of mathematics.
Brady Haran: There's a little bit of
complicated mathematics there are,
Daniel Litt: That's right.
Brady Haran: But,
I can still appreciate
what Dehn did--
the cleverness of it-- that he found it-- that he
realized those edges were the problem?
Daniel Litt: Yeah, that was clever.
Well, I think the really
amazing thing is
he knew, well, the lengths of the edges don't stay the same
and the dihedral angles don't stay
the same when you cut things up,
but there's some funny way of combining
them all together. That does stay the same.
That's really the miracle
of the Dehn Invariant.
Brady Haran: Clever.
Daniel Litt: Yeah.
Brady Haran: Good thesis.
Brady Haran: I bet there was no questioning
about giving him his doctorate.
Daniel Litt: Yeah, I mean, he went on to do a lot of
amazing stuff to the rest of mathematics too.
But yeah, this was
an amazing start.
[Brady Haran laughs]
Brady Haran: Cool!
Because the hotel's full, but the manager
is clever, and here's what he does:
He shifts the person
in Room 1 to Room 2,
and the person
in Room 2 to Room 3,
in Room 3 to Room 4,
and so on.
Everyone gets shifted
forward one room,
and because there are
infinitely many rooms,
you never run out of
rooms to put people in.